today the mattwell show my what is a
woman College Tour gets off to a roaring
start there are a few moments from last
night that are worth further discussion
we'll talk about that also the Governor
of Oklahoma pledges to ban child gender
transitions the movement is growing
across the country plus after lots of
stops and starts it seems that Elon Musk
will finally take over Twitter and you
can imagine the left is not very happy
about that in our daily cancellation a
new dating app targeting conservatives
earns derision from the left we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
Supreme Court decision to overturn Roe
is a huge albeit long overdue step in
the right direction but there's still a
long way to go to rid our country of
abortion many companies are bowing to
the woke mob by donating to pro-choice
causes and candidates or reimbursing
their employees travel expenses so that
if they live and work in a pro-life
State they can travel to a pro-abortion
state get an abortion be back at work on
Monday which is all of course these
companies care about what if I told you
that if you're currently on a phone plan
with one of the major carriers you might
be supporting these companies and their
pro-abortion agendas with your monthly
phone bill don't let abortionists use
your money to fund policies you don't
believe in switch to Charity mobile
instead Charity mobile is a pro-life
pro-family cell phone company that sends
five percent of your monthly plan price
to the pro-life charity of your choice
you don't have to compromise on values
or good phone service Charity mobile
offers the latest 5G phones no device or
service contracts great Nationwide
coverage and Live customer service based
right here in the U.S the fight for the
right to life continues and pro-life
causes need your support you can help by
simply switching your phone service to
Charity mobile today call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code Walsh to redeem a free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com and
mention code Walsh
so yesterday I began officially my what
is a woman College tour with our first
stop at Catholic University in
Washington DC I'm happy to report that
it was a very successful event
tremendous turnout we screened the film
earlier in the day and filled the room
for the screening and then actually
filled a second room for the screening
too it wasn't enough room in the first
room then we moved to the speech in the
Q a where we packed the campus
Auditorium to capacity and above I'm
told we had around 750 people which I'm
also told is the second highest turnout
for a speaker at Catholic University in
its history behind only the pope so I
have to take second place to the pope
which is okay there was a leftist
counter event that was meant to I guess
pull attendance away from us a little
bit of counter programming strategy and
that attracted 40 people so the final
score was 750 to 40. just like that's
like uh you know if an NBA team played
in the WNBA kind of like that's what the
final score would be and I don't mean to
gloat about it that's not my point I
mean I do mean to gloat about it but all
I have a couple of uh thoughts after
last night that I wanted to share a
couple of moments I think are worth
talking about so
one of the women who got up to speak
during the Q a was a mother from Fairfax
County who's uh been fighting to get
pornographic material removed from
uh the school's there and she's met lots
of resistance and and so far has not
been able to get it all
removed you know because uh of course
it's extremely controversial to suggest
that kids should not be given
pornography as reading material in class
as she described her efforts
um and uh you know and talked about it
people in the crowd began to applaud and
pretty soon they were all standing so
this mom ended up receiving a lengthy
Standing Ovation for you know what she's
been doing to fight against this madness
at her school board meetings which uh
made her quite emotional as well because
she said that she felt alone in the
fight and felt somewhat helpless and
appreciated the encouragement
now this is something that I encounter
often when I'm on the road uh all the
time uh conservatives who tell me that
they they feel like they're totally
alone I hear from people all the time
who tell me that
um they enjoy listening to this show
because it makes them feel sane it lets
them know that they're not the only ones
in the world who think this way
but of course they're not the only ones
of course they're not
see this is one of the great lies that
our culture tells it makes you believe
that if you have basic common sense if
you have what we now call Traditional
Values if you believe in basic moral
decency if you think that uh we
shouldn't be giving porn to kids in
school if you're not on board with the
lgbtification of everything in life then
uh you're a freak we're told you're a
weirdo you're alone
you know
because the left owns all of the Power
structures in society it can then
isolate and alienate those who oppose it
it can Gaslight telling you that you
must be crazy right you're the strange
one if you don't believe that men can
have babies
and if it cannot successfully trick you
into abandoning your beliefs
you know it wants to get you to kind of
look around and say well everyone
disagrees with me on this it seems like
I mean I feel like it must be true it's
pretty obvious to me everyone disagrees
and so maybe I'm wrong you know how
could the whole world be right or wrong
and I'm the only one who's right but if
it can't get you to abandon your beliefs
like that
at least they want you to feel hopeless
like there's no point in defending
yourself or your beliefs the fight is a
futile
but this again is all a lie
I am a right-wing terrorist extremist
I'm told and if I can go on to a college
campus and have 750 kids show up uh
that's a pretty good indication that we
are larger in number
than it may sometimes seem we're not as
alone as we feel at times and it's
important to realize that because
the other reason why they want you to
think you're alone is so that you don't
attempt to mobilize and organize
that's exactly what we need to be doing
there was one other moment last night
that might be worth further comments so
there was a young lady who got up to ask
I think a very fair question
she said if I'm such a Critic of the
so-called gender affirming if I'm the
critic of the gender affirming model if
I don't believe that we should be
affirming a child in their gender
confusion then what approach would I
recommend
that was the question we'll play that
exchange for you now
we can see from your documentary that um
the affirmative model of treating gender
dysphoria through transition is taking
the wrong approach of addressing a
really serious issue so my question is
what would you say is a better approach
to ultimately help those who experience
the real pain of gender dysphoria that
does not involve transitioning
yeah I think I guess I would advocate
for
the approach that was generally used
up until extremely recently which is
that if somebody is confused
about who they are about their identity
then we try to treat that confusion you
know we see the confusion itself as the
problem
uh you're not the problem you know your
body is not the problem there's nothing
wrong with with you as a as a person
nothing wrong with your body it's uh
there's something going on going on in
your mind and so we're gonna we're gonna
help you
accept yourself for who you really are
and that's that's one of the things I
hate so much about what they call the
gender affirming model is that
what that means is that you've got
people coming in especially kids
who hate themselves and they hate their
bodies
and they see themselves as as
ugly and monstrous
and what they're hearing and there might
be rainbow flags and smiles and
everything attached to it but what
they're hearing from the therapist is
you're right
you should feel that way about yourself
and I just find that
it's abominable it really is and so I
would Advocate an approach of true
self-acceptance except accept yourself
for who you are if you are a girl that's
a beautiful thing if you're a boy that's
a beautiful thing it's a wonderful thing
and it's okay to be that
so what I'm trying to point to there is
um is self-acceptance see when I was a
kid
self-acceptance was a big deal we heard
about it all the time when I was a kid
you grew up in the 90s you were
constantly hearing about self-acceptance
and you should accept yourself for who
you are it was preached constantly uh
all the time love yourself for who you
are they said and there was a time when
I admit I kind of argued against that
emphasis because I believed that it
breeds narcissism and self-involvement
if you're telling people all the time to
focus on themselves accept themselves
also I figured nobody really needs much
help in accepting themselves I mean you
are yourself
what can you do but accept it
but that was before
gender ideology grabbed our society by
the throat
and now that it has self-acceptance
takes on a new meaning and new urgency
because the culture now
encourages people especially kids
to reject and hate themselves when a
child goes to a therapist or a doctor or
a guidance counselor or often now a
parent
saying that she feels as though her body
is all wrong but she's all wrong her
very person is somehow wrong she she's
she is then greeted with affirmation
but what are they affirming they're not
affirming her as a as a self
that's all they're doing it's herself
that she hates and rejects
so they are affirming
that hatred and rejection they're not
affirming her they're affirming how she
feels about herself they are agreeing
with her that herself is wrong is ugly
is sick is broken
is in need of drastic medical and
cosmetic intervention
she hates her girlhood
you know she hates who she are and she's
told Yeah well yeah you should hate it
you're not wrong for hating it
here you go take these pills
uh get this get this surgery
we will help you destroy the parts of
you that you cannot bring yourself to
accept
that's the affirmation model
and it is as I said in the clip an
abominable
contemptible message
now the gospel uh preaches about
self-denial
as a as a positive good
but this is not the kind of self-denial
that we're talking about okay it's one
thing to subordinate your own desires in
service to a greater good
which is the sort of self-denial that we
should practice and we should promote
that's good self-denial
but the satanic Gospel of leftism urges
us to deny our very nature to deny our
very selfhood
and to attempt to demolish ourselves and
build a new self out of the rubble
but here's here's the problem is that
when you do that
and you tear yourself to pieces and you
even uh cut pieces of yourself off
you're still left with yourself
it's still yourself even after it's been
rebuilt
that's the LIE
you can't actually escape yourself
you can't escape who you fundamentally
biologically are
you can only become a more broken
version of what you once were
and that's what and that's what happens
and this takes on a very uh grotesque
and literal sort of connotation
oftentimes when
a girl goes in for you know
quote-unquote bottom surgery and they
are literally peeling parts of her body
off to to attach to other parts of her
body to try to make a new body but it's
not a new body it's all still you it's
just been rearranged in a grotesque
unnatural very disordered way
what was once natural and good and
functional is now unnatural and and
destructive and uh and not functional
so what approach should we be taking
it's an approach of self-acceptance we
say to uh people who are struggling with
this that there's there's actually
nothing wrong with you there's nothing
wrong with who you are
um it's it's good that you are who you
are
and you should accept that and love that
about yourself
and then help them get there
that should be the approach
now let's get to our five headlines
you know chain stores have different
price tiers for professional mechanics
and do-it-yourselfers but rockauto.com's
prices are the same for everybody and
they're reliably low rockauto.com offers
the lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like Airlines do rockauto.com
is a family-owned business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years they
have everything from engine control
modules and Brake Parts to tail lamps
motor oil and even new carpet whether
that's for your classic or your daily
driver you can get everything you need
with just a few easy clicks delivered
straight to your door quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brands the specifications and
the prices you prefer
amazing selection they've always got
reliably low prices too all the parts
your car will ever need
rockauto.com so all you got to do is go
to rockauto.com right now and see all
the parts available for your car or
truck rockauto.com and as always be sure
to write Walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that I sent
you
okay so Chris Ruffo reports some good
news here as the movement spreads uh
it's he says Oklahoma governor Stitt has
signed legislation blocking Oklahoma
Children's Hospital from conducting
child sex change interventions including
puberty blockers hormones and genital
surgeries uh he has vowed to ban the
practice Statewide
in the next legislative session and the
statement here from the governor's
office I'm pulling it up it says today
Governor Stitt signed SB 3xx which
blocks funding to prevent gender
transition services for minors at
Oklahoma Children's Hospital at OU
Health the bill wanted to effect
immediately upon the governor's
signature uh Governor Stitz said by
signing this bill today we are taking
the first step to protect children from
permanent gender transition surgeries
and therapies it is wildly inappropriate
for taxpayer dollars to be used for
condoning promoting or performing these
types of controversial procedures on
healthy children and he continued I'm
calling for the legislator to ban all
irreversible gender transition
transition surgeries and hormone
therapies and minors when they convene
next session we can now turn a blind eye
to what's happening all across our
nation as Governor will not allow
life-altering transition surgeries on
minor children in the state of Oklahoma
so by the way Oklahoma uh Governor Stitt
he's definitely one of the good ones
Oklahoma has their act together
um and uh they're one of the states that
I believe last year banned CRT in
classrooms and
so they're getting it together and we
see how this uh movement is growing
to ban the castration and mutilation of
children
um and the good news is that there's a
there's a a Snowball Effect here because
you know when one state does it when you
see this this movement in one state in
one area and then the pressure the
pressure is on in other states
especially red States uh like why
haven't you done the same thing
now
to
to protect all kids across the country
to legally protect all kids across the
country from this kind of abuse
you know that's uh that's not something
we're gonna be able to do overnight
because we know in blue States
just like what happened with a with
abortion uh when they see that it's
being banned in certain States they're
going to respond by being even more
radical
so what they're going to do is they're
going to go the opposite way
they're going to start and we're already
seeing this happening actually they're
going to start lowering the age limit
for all of these kinds of surgeries
and as California has done they're going
to say we're a sanctuary State now for
child sex change operations uh you know
come to us and we'll yeah we'll we'll
mutilate your child's genitals
so that's what's going to happen in blue
States
um I'm not we of course cannot be
satisfied with that okay this is not one
of those things right well it's a states
rights issue and that you know as long
as we can just take care of your own
State and that's all that matters uh no
the the kids who live in blue States
kids who live in California it's not
their fault they live in California they
didn't choose that so we're not going to
abandon them but that's going to take
Federal action
and that means winning back to housing
center and also winning the the White
House in 2024.
and that also means
um
sending the message to any presidential
candidate or any candidate running for
the house or Senate
that you need to come out fully in
support of these laws to ban this kind
of child abuse
you know we we as voters need to send
the message that we are not going to
support you unless you make clear that
this will be high on your agenda
and
but in the red States before we get
there there's no reason why we can't
pass these bans in every single red
state
and as I'm always reminding people one
of the reasons they haven't been banned
yet
is that
many average voters in these states
didn't realize this was happening they
just didn't it was Unthinkable to them
they couldn't imagine that this was
happening if anyone brought it up to
them they would have assumed that it's
already illegal
and now that we're getting the message
across that no it is happening
um I think pressure is building in the
red states to to ban this which is good
uh and it's especially important now as
planned parenthood gets more and more
into the child transition game so
Planned Parenthood we've cut into their
business significantly
uh you know not allowing them to perform
abortions in many states and so they're
losing a lot of that child murder money
and now what they're saying is well
we'll try to we'll try to recoup those
losses by if we can't kill the kids in
every state
um we can at least mutilate and castrate
them
and so here's a video that Planned
Parenthood put out a an ad for puberty
blockers let's watch this
there's no one-size-fits-all puberty
experience if your trans intersex or
non-binary know that you're not the only
one feeling confused
for some intersex people puberty may
start later than age 14.
you might experience some of puberty's
changes and not others and your body may
or may not go through puberty on its own
there are medicines you can take to help
your body start the process like hormone
replacement therapy some people decide
on hormones or surgeries to help their
bodies match up to their gender identity
or how they feel inside about themselves
your gender identity is real you should
be the one to decide what changes you
want to make to your body if you're
transgender or non-binary you may find
that your puberty experiences don't line
up with your gender identity or how you
see yourself that feeling can be
uncomfortable scary and stressful if
that sounds like you know that you're
not alone
there are medicines you can take to
delay puberty for a while they're called
puberty blockers and they work like a
stop sign by halting the hormones
testosterone and estrogen that cause
puberty changes like facial hair growth
and periods puberty blockers are safe
and can give you more time to figure out
what feels right for you your body and
your gender identity you don't have to
have all of the answers right now so
remember it's all a work in progress and
it may take time to figure out what
feels right to you but talking to a
trusted adult and a nurse or doctor may
help want to learn more go to
plannedparenthood.org teens
these people are just demonic monsters
uh and uh and you know this is like I
said this is it's not a coincidence that
we're seeing Planned Parenthood they've
been giving out hormones and that sort
of thing for years now but they're
doubling down on it now and that's not a
coincidence because this is It's a
money-making operation which just like
we saw at Vanderbilt big money big money
and it's it's the same here
um so they're looking to recoup their
losses from not being able to kill as
many kids as they were killing before
and so instead they're going to you know
can't can't kill the kids you could
still
uh in effect to kill off parts of them
anyway
now that right there 90 seconds is just
kind of a perfect summary of uh the the
misinformation campaign
that promotes this stuff
so they begin by talking about intersex
and you know actual medical conditions I
mean there are medical uh there's
something there's the medical conditions
like like precocious puberty for example
where
um children go through puberty much much
earlier than they're supposed to so and
then intersex now that that is uh those
are people that suffer medical
conditions deformities genetic mutations
and so on
so they they take that
and they lump that in with trans and
gender identity and all the rest of that
when the two things are not related at
all and it is perfectly possible and in
fact in states that have already banned
this stuff they they put things in the
law saying that okay the the medical and
surgical gender transition of minors is
illegal
end of sentence
if a child has an actual physical
medical condition like for example
precocious puberty then obviously you
can treat that
so it's it's not hard to delineate
between these two things legally or
morally
because they are completely different
the rest of the video is talking about
physically healthy children
say a physically healthy boy
who is unambiguously a boy there's no
question about that everything is
physically normal
but he comes into Planned Parenthood and
because he has a certain self-perception
we're going to give him drugs to align
himself with that self-perception and
you see this I the the the the notion of
selfhood that you get from the left
where
you know it's almost like this there's
this constant push and pull in battle
and negotiation that goes on between
yourself and your body
okay it's this it's this very strange
sort of dualism
that they envision
where yourself is separate from your
body and it's actually possible to
distinguish between the two there's who
you are and then there's your body those
are two completely different things they
say
and sometimes they don't align and so
there's this it's almost like this this
uh this zero-sum game this battle
between the two
and in order to in order to make
yourself align with your body you can
take uh drugs and and it should it's
well it's a stop sign they always think
of new metaphors
maybe it's pausing music or in this case
it's just uh put up a stop sign you can
put up a stop sign
and your your biology
you know your
your your nature will obey that stop
sign and just kind of hang out there
okay I'll stop here
until you decide what you want to do
moving forward
but it doesn't work that way that's not
how our bodies work that's not how
nature works
okay nature is is an Unstoppable Force
you can't just put up a stop sign and
say I don't want this
um there are things you can do to stymie
nature
there are things you can do to try to
evade it to suppress it you could do
yeah you can do all of that
but you're going to pay a price for it
it's always a trade-off
all right representative Corey Bush was
on ABC where she was asked about the
defund the police movement
and
here's what she said about that
you've stuck by it in fact you're one of
the few Democrats now who still says
let's defund the police are you worried
at all that that could hurt some of your
colleagues going into the midterm
elections see the thing about defund the
police is we have to tell the entire
narrative people here defund the police
but you know what they'll say say
reallocate say divest say move uh but
it's still the same thing we can't get
caught up on the words we people spend
more time focusing on the word defund
than they spend on caring and addressing
the problem of police violence in this
country
most mainstream Democrats have run have
have fled from the defund the police
movement they are now terrified of it
and they are hoping especially as we go
into the midterms that that voters
forget any of that ever happened
um even though it certainly did happen
and as we've played the clips before uh
in you know it wasn't all that long ago
I don't know like a year ago when every
mainstream Democrat right up to the top
right up to the White House
was coming out in support of defunding
the police and Corey bush is correct
that sometimes they used other language
I don't like the word defund we'll uh
we'll how about reallocate well we're
not gonna I'm not gonna take the funds
away we're just going to send the funds
somewhere else
which seems the same to me I don't know
so they're running away from it
because as we see
you know leftist policies
um
if you're if you're a very naive person
leftist policies maybe can sound
appealing in theory now they don't sound
appealing to me even in theory
but if you're very very naive maybe
maybe they do I don't know
and so maybe in theory you uh you you
might say to yourself oh that sounds
kind of nice so we why do we want to
send cops into every situation we'll
send a therapist
that sounds like a nice idea if there's
someone who's you know a bad guy with a
gun shooting people
send a therapist there to talk to him
and maybe the bad guy will say oh you
know what you're right I shouldn't be
doing this he'll drop the gun turn his
life around and next thing you know he's
a heart surgeon
so if you're very naive you have no idea
how the world Works maybe you find that
convincing
but then what happens when
uh the leftists are able to take these
ideas and bring them out of the realm of
theory and put them into action what you
find is just
abject misery and disaster
which is why Democrats are running away
from it but Cory bush is nuts I really I
appreciate Corey Bush that she's not
willing to let this go and uh she is
going I think now she has a memoir she
just wrote A Memoir so now she's on this
is perfect timing really so now she's
doing the media she's doing the media
tour to promote her book and right
before the midterms and everywhere she
goes she's reminding people that no we
as Democrats we do believe in defunding
the police
foreign
here's the latest project Veritas video
Andy Noe reports Tyler Wren is a far
left teacher who resigned in disgrace
from Owasso schools but now teaches in
Tulsa Will Rogers High School has been
exposed in a project Veritas sting
talking again about indoctrinating
students
let's watch
a little bit of this I don't know how
these people keep
I don't know how project Veritas
continues to do this
but uh but I appreciate it
I mean when you're
don't you know by now that you're like
someone sits down with you and and they
want to get you talking about all your
crazy left-wing ideas don't you get a
little suspicious
and they've got their maybe their purse
with the hidden camera you know right
there pointing right at your face
I don't know but here's the video
I am an anarchist or the only thing
that's a problem here is that a house
built 1775 or something
I can get my license
foreign
just deposit there he says I want to
burn down the entire system
here we have a leftist again pretending
to be raging against the system well how
can you burn down the system uh you you
are the system this this is what the
system is
you represent the system
as someone who identifies as a far left
militant with purple hair and big
earrings you know uh
that's the system that is it's a perfect
representation of the system
so you burn it down you're burning
yourself down
I mean be my guest
you want to burn down the school system
metaphorically I'm I'm with you
I'll be I'll be right there with you
with a torch with a metaphorical torch
on me
let's keep watching
[Music]
too much last message yeah but like
um eventually you want to like remove
Christianity from her religion from
Progressive thought because like
religion is
yes that is Tyler Wren he used to teach
at the Owasso Eighth Grade Center until
he resigned last April after these Tick
Tock videos were highlighted by Libs of
tick tock if your parents don't love and
accept you for who you are this
Christmas [ __ ] them I'm your parents now
I'm proud of you drink some water I love
you bye I have a rather
talk following I am I'm an authority
figure so I'm going to give out a
Christmas message of like hey if your
parents don't love and support you for
who you are this Christmas
them I'm your parents now I love you
drink some water proud of me his Tick
Tock page back door is his secret
curriculum here is a list of books that
Tyler wants to hide from parents on his
Tick Tock link tree I would say uh gen Z
is like super Progressive oh I know I
taught in Missouri last year no not last
year but two years ago I taught a uh
like a philosophy like 101 class we took
a political quiz
we always hear this from these people
that uh you know gen Z they're they're
super Progressive they're they're
they're totally on board for this in uh
my film what is a woman which you can
watch if you go to what is one.com
is something we heard from a lot of the
uh the leftists we talked to where they
said they said uh you know the Gen Z
they're taking they you know you know
you know who gets it gen Z the youngest
generation they get it
they're they're taking the lead here
and of course uh first of all
no you don't you don't put the youngest
Generations in a position of leadership
we don't look to the Young Generation
for leadership we're supposed to be
leading them so that's backwards to
begin with
but also
why are they super Progressive well
because of you
so he's sitting here admitting that he
has embarked on this indoctrination
campaign that he's hiding from the
parents
and uh and then he says oh all these
kids are super Progressive well I wonder
why that is
when they're indoctrinated pretty much
from birth in the public school system
and by the time they get to eighth grade
they're quote super Progressive I mean
what a coincidence
who could have ever imagined that that
outcome
and this is Again full on
cult indoctrination
it cannot be emphasized enough that this
is in fact that's not uh I know you know
we use the word cult and cultish
probably too much it gets overused
but that is actually what is happening
in the public school system and so if
you send your kids to public school
there may be some Public Schools where
it's not as bad as others
uh but there isn't any good public
school left
because it's all a part of this system
and it's a fundamentally broken system
but if you send your kid to public
school system then you are sending them
in to
encounter and
endure
and probably be
uh
destroyed by
this cult-like method of indoctrination
what does he do he says well your
parents don't love you I love you I'm
the one who really cares about you
you don't need your parents
you have me
now that's a that's a grooming tactic
also that's a that's a tactic of a
sexual abuser that's a grooming sexual
abuse tactic
uh it's also a cult indoctrination Tech
these things are all related
what do you want to do you you sever a
person's attachments to other people in
their life if there's any if there's
anyone else that a person you you the
the potential cult in inductee uh if
there's anyone else that they look to
for advice for guidance for leadership
if they are orienting themselves based
on anyone else you want to sever that
relationship
because you want them looking to you
into the system that you are a part of
that's what's happening there all right
the Daily Mail has this rather pathetic
story says Howard Stern left his house
for the first time in two years to dine
with other a-listers including Jennifer
Aniston and Jason Bateman despite
despite admitting it was too much for
the germaphobe Stern 68 finally left his
20 million dollar apocalypse bunker in
Southampton to enjoy an Israeli meal at
Laser wolf in Williamsburg Brooklyn on
Friday night after he and his wife Beth
were invited out by late night talk show
host Jimmy Kimmel remember there was a
time when Howard Stern was seen as some
sort of rebel
he was a kind of provocative rebellious
figure
and now he's this pathetic old man
hiding in his Mansion for two years and
only finally because he's scared and
only finally comes out to have a Swanky
dinner
with A-list actors
despite being in great company rubbing
elbows with the likes of Justin throw
and Jon Hamm the radio host said he was
in a panic the whole time
I said to my wife I don't want to go I'm
in a panic I don't want to get covered I
know our president has told us the
pandemic is over and everyone is walking
around without masks I still just don't
want to get covered
who so I guess that's what he was saying
on his show after the fact
who is still listening to a show is my
question
what's the audience for this
I know the audience like back in the day
the audience for Howard Stern was just
working class men who appreciated Howard
Stern because he was Politically
Incorrect and he was again a rebellious
kind of figure and he just you know and
he was funny and so that's why they
liked him
um are there still working class
people are there like a plumber's
driving
to their next job and listening to this
68 year old multi-millionaire talk about
the fact that he's still scared of covid
so he hides in his Mansion but he
finally went out because he wanted to
meet Jennifer Aniston John Hamm for
dinner is that the kind of thing that
working-class people are listening to
so I'm I am curious about that who
exactly is the audience maybe I mean
probably there just isn't one anymore
but it does go to show how again how the
coveted Panic was always driven
maybe oddly kind of counter-intuitively
by a rejection of our mortality
not an acknowledgment of it but a
rejection
okay it's not that it's not that the
people who are panicking over covid and
some of them still are like Howard Stern
it's not that they uh you know they they
have more of a respect for our frail
Human Condition than the rest of us do
no it's it's a they actually reject
their mortality
Howard Stern is almost 70 years old
he's only got
you know average life expectancy would
put him at you know maybe he's got 15
years left If he if he lives the average
lifespan for a man
on the upper end of that maybe he's got
two decades left at most
you know he has lived the vast majority
of his lives the vast majority of his
lifespan is behind him
for sure
and yet he's hiding in his house so he
doesn't get sick
as if by so he's he's giving up on
you know the last years of his life
to avoid dying
even though death is a certainty anyway
like Howard you're definitely going to
die within 20 years probably sooner than
that
it's it is 100 going to happen
and you're also going to get sick
um you're gonna get cancer if you
haven't already
did you know that every if you live long
enough everybody gets cancer everyone if
you live long enough
um if you if you live a life and never
get cancer it's because you died of
something else before you could get it
and you can't hide from cancer
you could you could stay in your
multi-million dollar bunker for the next
10 years it's not going to stop cancer
from getting you cancer comes from
within
that's happening inside your body
so what's the point exactly it's like
that was what many of us who were not
panicking said all along it's no I yeah
I get that we could die I understand
that
I understand that we're mortal and but
that's why I'm going to continue to live
my life because I'm going to die anyway
and it's it's a it's a one it's life has
a 100 death rate
so what are you trying to accomplish
very sad
um
oh we have to mention this from the
daily wire Twitter indicated Tuesday
afternoon that they are moving forward
with letting Elon Musk acquire the
company after the billionaire
entrepreneur informed the company in a
letter that he wanted to proceed with
the purchase for the original offer of
54. and 20 cents per share musk made the
proposal in a letter to Twitter
Executives which sent share prices
surging by as much as 22 percent
the company sent a statement Twitter
issued this statement about today's news
we received the letter from musk parties
which they have filed with the SEC the
intention of the companies to close the
transaction at 54.20 per share uh
Twitter had been battling musk and
Cordova's attempt to cancel a previous
offer to buy the company for 44 billion
dollars must Express concern that the
actual share of fake accounts on the
platform could range as high as 33
percent rather than the company's
reported five percent so
so anyway he was trying to get out of it
but it seems like he realized that he
was going to lose in court and so now
now Elon Musk is being forced to
purchase this multi-billion dollar
company which I mean this is like the
kind of problem you can only have if
you're the richest man in the world
you're being forced to purchase a
multi-billion dollar company
um maybe unfortunate for him works out
great for the rest of us I mean I
couldn't be happier about it
um
because it seems as though Elon Musk is
actually going to take over Twitter
and I am just going to go
crazy on Twitter with the misgendering
I'm going to be misgendering everybody
all over the place
and I I'm very excited for that now
there are two reactions to this that I
want to note kind of representative of
the of the whole
so first this is from
Ben Collins who's a senior reporter for
NBC News
and he obviously is very upset about
this
and he says for those of you asking yes
I do think this site can and will change
pretty dramatically if musk gets control
over it no there is no immediate
replacement if it gets done early enough
based on the people he's aligned with
yes it could actually affect the
midterms
if musk is really taking this site
private there are no real guard rails
anymore rule making can be capricious it
can Elevate any idea or person he wants
through recommendations and ux choices
and there will be no oversight on this
as a private company
this is great for a few reasons first of
all he's ba he's admitting that Twitter
suppresses and censors and does it to
help the Democrats in the midterms and
what that means is that if they're not
able to do that anymore then it will
affect the midterms and it will be worse
for the Democrats
but I also love how he says that that
well when musk takes over
there's rule making will now now all of
a sudden rule the rules on Twitter will
be arbitrary and capricious
yes I can only imagine it's it's you
know that's that's it's hard to imagine
a scenario where Twitter or any other
social media company would have
arbitrary and capricious rules
that are enforced unfairly and unevenly
targeting certain groups of people while
letting others off the hook
can you imagine that I can't
nothing like it has ever happened
I also can't imagine this from Robert
Reich
uh Berkeley Professor he says
when multi-billionaires take control of
our most vital platforms for
communication it's not a win for free
speech it's a win for oligarchy well
once again
uh I also cannot imagine this I cannot
imagine
billionaires owning social media
companies this will be the first one
Elon Musk will be the first billionaire
it's kind of maybe it's breaking a glass
ceiling in a certain way he's going to
be the first billionaire apparently
really the first rich guy
to own a social media platform before
this all the social media platforms were
were owned by Working Class People they
were owned by you know like plumbers and
they were owned by Working Class People
you know Facebook Instagram
tick tock
even Twitter prior to this
the the Twitter board consisted of I
guess I don't know School teachers and
uh electricians and people who work at
Walmart
is what we're supposed to believe anyway
which of course is totally absurd
now let's get to the comments section
[Music]
it's a sweet baby game
Scott says Knowles told us today that
you did you two did in fact decide on
what the best on what the bet would be
in your fantasy football game and he's
saying that because you lost you took
your
you took your sweet daddy title and
wants to be called Sweet Daddy Knowles
but don't worry Daddy because all your
sweet babies know this is just an
outrageous lie and we will not
acknowledge his self-proclaimed title
trust me says hey Matt I've been a mole
on Michael Knowles's show and he's
actively claiming the Sweet Daddy title
and viciously slandering you
I did the best I could to pop his bubble
and stand up for the SPG but
unfortunately comments on a YouTube
video can only do so much stand up and
fight you've earned the title and no one
else can claim it SPG for life so I've
got a lot of comments like this uh
Knowles apparently is just moving
forward and referring to himself as
Sweet Daddy
appropriating
our culture he's a he's in fact this is
cultural appropriation of the sweet baby
gang and he's doing that also when he
knows that I'm out
traveling the country for my what is a
woman College Tour
so I can't confront them on it directly
but the fact remains that yes we talked
about a bet
for our fantasy football matchup this
past weekend we talked about it but we
never settled on on what the BET was you
can go back check the tape all right go
back watch the members block I think
from lat from this past Friday
we discussed what the BET might be you
know what happens if you lose and we
talked about various different things
um I suggested that if he loses he
should have to eat a whole jar of
mayonnaise just because that's the first
thing that came to mind it would be
gross and funny to watch him try to
attempt it but we never settled on it we
never we never arrived at any conclusion
we said we would reconvene we never did
and so what that means is the BET was
off
by default
and then I went on to lose
but even so the BET was off
you can see it for yourself
uh John Smith says Matt Walsh isn't some
based conservative he's just a regular
dad from the 90s that accidentally
tripped into a Time Wormhole and started
a podcast
I don't know if you meant that as an
insult or not but uh but I I have I take
no issue with that characterization I
think that that's actually a pretty good
description
that that is that is how we should start
describing the show
in its description on Apple podcast and
Spotify
um
gen Z says I knew this letter calling on
the doj to arrest you was coming I just
knew it and I knew that you would never
back down this truly is your mission
Matt thank you so much we're with you
all the way
uh well of course it's I mean this is
here's what I would say if if I ever
backed away from this
and said well you know I'm not gonna I'm
not going to talk about this issue
anymore I'm going to de-emphasize it or
you know maybe maybe the other side
maybe there is something to what they're
to what they're saying if I ever said
that then
really you should assume that I've
completely lost my mind you should call
guys and white coats to come take me
away
because it would mean that I've
completely lost it but that would also
never happen
there is as I said
literally nothing they could threaten
because then I'd be what abandoning
objective truth
and once you abandon objective truth
there's nowhere else to go there's
nothing else
to do there's there's nothing else to
talk about
um eyes like the summer says one of my
favorite quotes from uh as far back as
my childhoods is I wish
this is from Lord of the Rings I guess I
wish it need not have happened in my
time said Frodo so do I said Gandalf and
so do all who lived to see such times
but that is not for them to decide all
we have to decide is what to do with the
time that it's given to us from The
Fellowship of the Ring
a little bit of inspiration there
from Lord of the Rings which I'm fine
with
a brand new series is available now on
daily wire plus and it's called
breakaways with Allison Williams if you
don't know the story Allison was a
successful ESPN sideline reporter but
when ESPN made the vaccine mandatory for
all employees she refused to get it for
a very valid reason she was trying to
get pregnant and was worried about the
potential side effects rather than take
the risk she quit well on breakaways
Allison sits down with athletes who took
a stand for their beliefs the first four
episodes feature Jonathan Isaac nick
rolovic uh Ennis Cantor freedom and Dana
White those episodes are available right
now with four episodes coming soon four
more episodes rather coming soon head to
dailywire.com Walsh right now to become
a member and watch the series that's
dailywire.com Walsh now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
so last week a brand new dating app
launched it enters into a crowded
Marketplace already populated by
something like 65 million other dating
apps but it seeks to set itself apart by
specifically targeting conservatives
some people from the Trump Camp
apparently have teamed up with Peter uh
Thiel to bring us what their What's
called the right stuff which is a
service which says that it was created
for conservatives to connect in
authentic and meaningful ways other
dating apps have gone woke the website
reads but we bring people together with
shared values and similar passions now a
commercial for the app went viral on
social media last week and here it is
check it out
today we brought in a group of
conservative young women and wanted to
get their honest opinions about what
they're looking for in the guys they
date
[Music]
what are you looking for in a partner
they just have to be a conservative
definitely someone that wants to have
kids
I like an independent man personally I
like the alpha male Vibe I want a man
who really loves his family definitely
someone whose faith is important to them
for me it's someone who actually wants
to meet my parents
why do you want a date a conservative
for me at least I know that we're going
to start off with some shared values
while the conservative men outdated at
least know how to treat me like a woman
in my personal experience conservative
guys have better manners I like that
they understand their role in the
relationship as a man
I just prefer my men to be masculine
and what's the biggest red flag when it
comes to dating a Democrat no Democrats
a Democrat can't be a Democrat a
Democrat that's easy a Democrat no
Democrats so no
foreign
[Music]
match download the right stuff today
now the acting of the commercial may not
be
award-worthy exactly but then again the
acting in most commercials is an
award-worthy the main point is the
concept and it's the concept that the
left has been mocking relentlessly
almost all of the reporting on the new
app is focused on how much people hate
it and are making fun of it the
independent reports quote people are
mocking new conservative dating app the
right stuff and the article helpfully
documents some of the lame jokes that
trolls have made about it quote
conservatives are such dorks launching a
dating app called The Right Stuff one
person tweeted while another said the
right stuff dating app sounds like the
stuff nightmares are made of
can't wait to not sign up someone else
joked
these are apparently the best insults
they could find for this article proving
yet again that although leftists may
love to troll which is a passion that I
in fact share with them they are really
not very good at it meanwhile The Daily
Dot reports uh quote some had a hard
time believing that most young women
looking for love would be content with
the type of relationship Dynamic this ad
suggests
quote uh wait until they're masculine
conservative says when I want your
opinion I'll ask for it or calls you
every day at noon to ask what's for
supper and tells you how his mother did
it another person tweeted one Twitter
user observed that the right stuff is
basically the dating app version of a
safe space for right Wingers
quote let's connect to hey let's connect
to hate immigrants and women's rights
someone else quipped another joke
someone said they're trying to build a
domestic terrorist database
well if I wanted to build a database of
the lamest nerds with the worst insults
I think we could probably we're off to a
good start here although there may
actually be some truth to what the last
guy said I I wouldn't be surprised if
the feds used an app like this to
catfish and entrap conservatives now the
good news though is that you can usually
spot the federal agents based on the
haircut or if he starts suggesting you
know on the first date that you should
try to kidnap the governor or something
then that's you know pretty good
indication
but in any case other leftist outlets
have accused the right stuff of uh of
many other things promoting misogyny
promoting traditional gender roles God
forbid they've blasted it for being
archaic old-fashioned divisive etc etc
they've mocked it belittled it been
offended by it and so on
they just really hate the idea of
conservatives trying to meet each other
get married have babies they really do
hate it The Daily Show with Trevor Noah
Noah got in on the action this week with
a painfully unfunny skit ridiculing the
conservative dating app
on the bright side the bit did extend
Trevor Noah's perfect unbroken streak of
unfunny jokes and he just announced that
he's leaving The Daily Show apparently
soon
um so it looks like he'll retire with a
batting average of one thousand when it
comes to being painfully witless and
unfunny so congratulations to him it is
an impressive accomplishment
but there are a few things here a few
points to make I think
first you have to keep in mind
that the people who make fun of things
like this are almost without exception
single childless and lonely and likely
destined to always remain so
much of what drives so many people in
our society today is the fact that they
are Lonesome and miserable and they want
you to be Lonesome and miserable too
it's one of the universal Timeless Facts
of Life misery loves company why does
Missouri love company well because
miserable people tend to believe that
happiness is kind of graded on a curve
so if they can make everyone else less
happy then their own happiness score
sort of is is raised when compared
against the average
now the math doesn't really work that
way but that won't stop them from
employing that strategy anyway in fact
they will not only try to steer you away
from things that will make you happy but
we'll even try to convince you
that you are unhappy when you aren't
so for example ever since I announced
that we have another set of twins on the
way I have heard from many nasty
comments from trolls insisting that I
cannot actually be happy as a married
man with six kids
the idea of finding contentment and joy
in a life of service to my wife and
children simply doesn't compute with
these shallow flimsy self-centered
little nothings their lives are devoted
entirely to their TVs and their phones
and maybe their pets
so I will grow old with my children and
grandchildren by my side they will grow
old with their Tick Tock accounts and
then they'll die and be forgotten and
leave behind no Legacy
this is the path to fulfillment they
insist
and since my path is the opposite of
what they've chosen they must convince
me that I should be miserable about my
life choices
but that's an impossible uphill battle
because sadly for them
I love my wife and children and can't
imagine a life without them
second point I don't know anything about
this particular dating app aside from
the commercial I don't know if the if
the user base is large enough for it to
actually work I don't know anything
about the app's functionality or lack
thereof when it comes to the execution
it could be a great service it could be
terrible it could be somewhere in
between I'm not really in a position to
test out data gaps so I can't I can't
give you a personal testimony one way or
another but what I can say
is that the idea behind it the idea that
people on the left are deriding
ruthlessly is good
and I want to focus on that on on on the
idea just the idea from because if you
are a mature adult
not looking to waste time not looking
for cheap hookups but rather Desiring a
healthy and committed and serious
relationship most dating apps currently
on the market are a waste of time
because they simply are not designed to
facilitate that sort of thing not
designed for you they're designed for
and mostly used by people who want to
use each other for momentary pleasure
and then move on to the next
so it can be difficult to sift through
all of that debris to find actual spouse
material
for that
um you need to find someone who shares
your fundamental values
you don't need to align perfectly on
every last issue you're not looking for
your carbon copy my wife is not a carbon
copy of me I I wouldn't want that I
wouldn't want to marry me I don't know
how she does it frankly but we do share
our core values and beliefs we're
building from the same Foundation
and if you build from the same
Foundation it's okay to disagree about
some of the furnishings and decorations
and everything which we do in my
marriage you know both the literal and
figurative sense
the other key is that both people in
relationship have to see marriage as the
logical and desired endpoint of dating
dating is is not an end in itself but
rather a vehicle
that takes you somewhere else so you
have to look at it it's a it's a vehicle
um and if both people cannot agree on
the destination or even that there is a
destination you just remain Stuck in
Neutral Forever Until one or both of you
gets bored
and bails out of the car which will
likely happen very quickly
and finally
the the man
in the relationship must Embrace his
role as a man and the woman as a woman a
relationship doesn't work if both people
involved don't understand that they
bring something unique and essential to
the arrangement that's what the the the
the much hated and feared gender roles
are really about
it's just about
emphasizing and acknowledging and
highlighting the fact
that as a man you bring something unique
and special to the relationship as a
woman you bring something unique and
special
by rejecting sex differences and gender
roles entirely people in romantic
relationships make themselves redundant
and useless with no idea about what
they're supposed to do or why confusion
and paralysis sets in and then the whole
thing breaks down
so
it certainly is the right approach the
right stuff you might say to go into the
dating scene looking for someone who
shares your values who sees marriage as
the end goal of dating and who Embraces
their masculinity as a man or their
femininity as a woman now whether this
particular dating app will successfully
facilitate all that I don't know
but I do know certainly that the leftist
critics in this case
are today canceled
that will do it for us today uh talk to
you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
John Bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
[Music]